huge leak last night in the Trump
investigation are you following this
okay I'll help you out yeah too late
once again man people were tired of this
guy anyway big leak in the Trump
investigation a list of questions that
robert muller wants to ask president
Trump was leaked to the media last night
yeah yeah it turns out ten of the
questions for Trump or just WTF dude our
seventh question
WTF dude it's come out that for years
President Trump has been taking a
prescription drug to combat hair loss
yeah yeah the drug side effects include
headaches dry mouth and running for
president just to promote your fake
University those are the possible side
effects
[Applause]
this is a nylon wig okay as of this
month as of this month Michael Cohen
reportedly now owes two hundred and
eighty thousand dollars to back taxes
yeah and that incredible there's a porn
star named back taxes due back in his
mind the leaders of South Korea China
and Japan are plenty to meet next week
to discuss North Korea yeah yeah yeah
yeah President Trump will not attend
because he says I'm tired of trying to
tell them apart
how're we doing everybody good ok go he
got free candy right ok good ok then
we're all good right Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos says he is planning to spend the
majority of his fortune getting himself
into space he wants to get into space
yeah he said I've seen what you people
buy and I don't want to be near you in
Florida now follow me
in Florida and I'll have to say is
Florida and you're with me right away in
Florida a man crashed his car was found
to be in possession of meth then tried
to flee the accident to get more meth
police are describing the man is armed
and consistent so they admire him Whole
Foods I don't you heard about this Whole
Foods is under fire for helping fund an
Asian restaurant called yellow fever
yeah the idea came from their CEO who
goes by the name white idiot
[Applause]
you